these were the videos Finley bowden's
parents wanted the world to see
but behind closed doors Shannon Marsden
and Stephen Bowden beat bruised and
burnt their baby son inflicting more
than 130 separate injuries that led to
severe infections
Finney died on Christmas Day 2020 just
10 months old
having brutally assaulted Finley on at
least two occasions you continued to
abuse him and you lied that he had
covered so that no one would see him and
remove him from your care and in doing
so you subjected your own baby song to
unimaginable cruelty
Finland was taken into Care at Birth
because of his parents drug use but at
eight months old he was returned to them
the court heard the couple lied to their
families and to Social Services saying
they were clean that their home in
Chesterfield was safe
but under two months later Finley was
dead and police found the family home
like this full of rubbish smelling of
urine and cannabis with a moldy milk
bottle next to the bed
the heartbreaking reality is that
Finley's last days
would have been spent in immense pain a
fact that would have been abundantly
clear to both parents
they knew that they were responsible for
those injuries and instead of doing the
right thing and taking Finley to get
urgent medical care
they took him shopping in Chesterfield
town center as though nothing were wrong
this was that outing captured on CCTV it
was Christmas Eve and the last time
Finley was seen alive a safeguarding
review is already underway because there
are questions as to why a family court
said that it was safe for Findlay to
return to his parents immediately and
full time when a social worker had
recommended a gradual return over four
months as well as regular drugs tests
for his parents
as they were sentenced today at Derby
Crown Court Finley's parents showed no
emotion but a statement was read out
written by their families who called the
couple monsters although we will never
forget Finley they said we will forget
you
Catherine Sky News Derby